the timing is right now we're very very
very happy happy anniversary prince
william
and kate middleton the duke and duchess
of cambridge are celebrating
10 years of marriage on thursday and to
honor their special day
they released two new portraits to
commemorate the milestone
one portrait taken outside kensington
palace earlier this week by chris floyd
features kate and prince william holding
hands
and sporting matching blue ensembles
kate wore a light blue dress with her
hair down
and gorgeous curls while prince william
opted for a blue sweater over matching
slacks
kensington royals shared the new photos
to their instagram account
captioning the post quote 10 years the
second portrait features a couple
in a sweet embrace
prince william and kate middleton tied
the knot at westminster abbey
on april 29 2011. nearly 2 000 people
attended the ceremony
including notable guests david and
victoria beckham elton john
david furnish and josh stone but it had
that magic that fairy tale romance this
was a young couple
who'd met at university fallen in love
and
survived the reality of the real world
when they eventually left st andrews
university
they had a long courtship before they
got engaged they'd been together
for ten years so by the time william did
propose
and the marriage was announced um for
april 2011
and the world was ready for a spectacle
and that's exactly
what they got and it comes at no
surprise that their wedding day
even became a national holiday in the uk
the duke and duchess went on to create
their own royal family with their three
children
prince george princess charlotte and
prince louis
william and kate's big anniversary comes
just weeks after the passing of prince
philip
after attending the duke of edinburgh's
intimate funeral service
the couple paid a special tribute to the
late prince during a visit to the air
cadets east ham
squadron at one moment during the event
the squadron paid tribute to phillip as
cayden williams smiled and watched
[Music]